bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france à l'heure la
proposition de valérie pécresse de
recourir à la reconnaissance faciale
dans les transports en commun prochain
propose un problème légal
un problème de droit oui bien entendu ça
ça pose un problème de droit parce que
le la reconnaissance faciale n'est pas
n'importe quelle technologie à la
différence de la vidéoprotection c'est
une technologie qui a des impacts
biométrique très important et en plus
les données récoltées ne sont pas des
données données par par des tiers mais
ça vient vraiment de du corps du visage
des individus qui vont être soient
authentifiés soient identifiés et le
traitement de ces données sont
aujourd'hui vraiment très très encadrés
par le paquet européen de protection des
données personnelles ce qu'on appelle là
le règlement général ou la protection
des données et la directive justice
police donc il faut vraiment pour cela
alain cadre légal est actuellement la
cnil dit d'ailleurs qu'il faut avant
tout avant tout et réglementations il
faut d'abord faire des expérimentations
et ses expérimentations doivent d'abord
définir des lignes rouges qu'on doit pas
franchir
ce qui n'est pas pour l'instant fait et
il faut donc vraiment entouré
toutes ces propositions d'un cadre en
amont une expérimentation avant une
réglementation ou une adoption d'une
législation
alors on va dire la ratp a tenté une
expérience au printemps avec le port du
masque une expérience qui a été
interrompu par la cnil poser problème
notamment concernant les protections de
données personnelles respect
liberté individuelle qui est que
deviennent ces données après avoir été
collectées qui est axé et quels sont les
risques
et justement la difficulté actuelle
c'est l'absence de réglementation pour
ses expérimentations la cnil pause avant
de pourrait avant de répondre à votre
question la cnil demande d'abord un
amont que l'on puisse savoir s'il n'y a
pas des technologies moins intrusif pour
les libertés individuelles
avant de choisir la reconnaissance
faciale et c'est ce qui s'est passé à la
fois dans des expérimentations dont vous
parliez à la ratp et puis de la même
manière vous savez c'est une tentative
aussi dans des lycées et là la cnil dit
qu'il faut auparavant
d'abord savoir si on peut pas atteindre
les objectifs qu'on se fixe avec des
technologies moins intrusive et
justement compte tenu des risques que
causent les la reconnaissance faciale en
matière de traitement des données
il faut s'assurer que ces données ne
soient pas conserver de façon illégitime
et même aujourd'hui n'est pas possible
de traiter ces données dans la directive
pour 10 justice pour l'instant on ne
peut même pas traiter les données en
question sauf s'il ya des causes
vraiment légitime et à ce moment là il
est possible de faire l'expérience à
sion puis il ya une autre exigence de la
cnil
c'est la possibilité pour tout individu
qui serait un suit ainsi donc reconnu
par cette voie là de pouvoir contrôler
les données c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'on ait accès chaque individu concerné
pas la reconnaissance faciale puissent
accéder aux données et demandé leur
suppression dans selon des règles qu'on
va fixer leurs dernières questions très
rapidement vous êtes professeur de droit
public en tant que voyageur
at on le droit aujourd'hui de s'opposer
à la captation de son image dans
l'espace public quels sont les recours
possibles absolument aujourd'hui l'idée
a des possibilités et bien sûr de
contester les données qui sont ainsi
récoltées sans notre consentement
les traitements de ces données ne
peuvent être faits que dans des raids et
de cadres de police d'en quête de police
ou de justice et on dispose de
différentes voies de recours en fonction
de type de l'infraction pour vous
reproche merci beaucoup joël
andriantsimbazovina d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de droit public